and this guy doesn't understand it i
think most of the left
does not understand this at all and it's
why they are losing their
freaking minds because this is
all that there is i don't know why i
mean if it were me if i really believe
this is all that there is i'd probably
just sit on my couch
and watch like old episodes of the
waltons or something i don't
i don't think but that's one thing you
can do or
because you just say oh well it's all
meaningless whatever this will be just
kind of pleasant i'll sit here have a
drink have a cigar watch
watch good tv and then and then die
someday but the the alternative is
you're just so you're so anxious you're
so
shocked and horrified at the reality
that you're staring into the abyss
that you you just go crazy and that that
is what's happened with the left
you you know i always try to reason with
the left try to engage with their
arguments
but there's no argument in ah
that's not no that's that's not an
argument that's
a a childish temper tantrum these
these protests you know these violent
riots that are going on
there's no arguing with that because
there's no reason in it there's no logic
in it
it's just a threat it's just an
explosion
of violence and and that they continue
even to this day there was a protest
quote unquote that took place
in the middle of the night two nights
ago outside of senator lindsey graham's
home
take a listen to this peaceful wonderful
subdued reasonable protest
you see the cops show up thankfully and
then there are these really nice
peaceful
orderly protesters trying to break onto
his property
some doughy sort of millennial looking
fellow just gets
pushed back by the cops cameras lights
banging noise those clappers
that noise that you're hearing there
that is the left's argument
in these protests the air horn
and the and the banging that is the
argument
you know in a self-governing republic
speech is politics and politics of
speech
meaning that when you can convey meaning
through your words through these sounds
and symbols we emit from our mouths
and then someone else can hear that and
have some idea of what you're talking
about because you're referring to
something in objective reality that is
speech
and the way we govern ourselves is we
persuade our fellow citizens
of things and then ultimately if we're
persuasive enough hopefully we win
elections and then get to govern
ourselves that's at least
how it's supposed to work that is what
freedom of speech is
is to protect that is what the first
amendment is to protect
freedom of speech quote unquote is not
there
to protect screaming and
clapping and yelling and blowing air
horns outside of a senator's home at
night
that's not speech the ah
and the whoo and the these kind of
animalistic
beastial sounds that these that these
people are making outside of lindsey
graham's home that's not speech
speech has to have meaning to it it has
to have substance
animals who grunt and scream like these
democrats do
do not have speech that isn't speech
that's sound that's noise
and that's what we're getting we're
getting a whole lot of noise
and we're getting a whole lot of noise
because this
is ultimately a religious expression
for eternal questions that politics are
certainly not
fit to solve or can only touch around
the surface of
this is the protest now is the is part
of the liturgy of liberalism
any time there's a police shooting for
instance even if it's a completely
justified police shooting
100 justified it doesn't matter that's
the signal then to go out and do this
liturgy like the church bells
in medieval europe the the kneeling down
and disrespecting the flag that's part
of
the liturgy of secular liberalism as
well
what did lindsey graham do did lindsey
graham do anything no but they just show
up and they start screaming because
that's their version of church because i
bet none of those people go to church on
sunday
and they feel like they need some
community and they feel like they need
some meaning in their life
and so instead of going and getting
salvation and being
in fellowship with the mystical body of
christ and ensuring your own salvation
what do they do they go yell and scream
in the middle of the night
like a bunch of banshees and idiots
but that's what that is i hope you
enjoyed that short segment from the
michael knowles show be sure to check
out the full episode linked in the
description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts